>> Greg: AOC WAS ON
"60 MINUTES" LAST NIGHT.
MUST BE ALL HER GREAT NEW IDEAS.
>> PEOPLE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
START PAYING THEIR FAIR SHARE OF
TAXES.
ONCE YOU GET TO THE TIPPY TOP,
YOU ARE TEN MILLION DOLLARS,
SOMETIMES YOU SEE TAX RATES AS
HIGH AS 60 OR 70%.
>> Greg: THE REAL STORY IS THE
MEDIA'S VIEW OF HER.
EVEN WITH HER OLD IDEAS, SHE
GETS ON "60 MINUTES."
THE PASS IS CALLED A FUTURE AND
YOU BETTER LOVE IT.
TAKE AOC'S DELIGHTFUL DANCING
VIDEO.
THE MEDIA CREATED A FAKE STORIES
OF THE CONSERVATIVE'S ATTACKED
HER.
NOT REALLY.
THE ONLY STORIES WRITTEN BY THE
DANCE WERE ABOUT LIBERALS USING
IT TO FALSELY SMEAR THE RIGHT.
THE PRESS CREATES A SHIELD
AROUND HER AND WHICH ANY
CRITICISM MUST BE DUE TO SEXISM
OR BIGOTRY WHEN INFECTED IN
THEIR HEADS AND NOT OURS.
REAL CRITICISM ABOUT HER ACTUAL
BELIEFS WHICH ARE RETREADS OF
HORRIBLE IDEAS FROM PREVIOUS
ENTRIES.
SOCIALISM WITH A SMILE.
FASCISM AMONG FRIENDS, VENEZUELA
MEETS VEGAN.
THE SAD NEWS IS WE HAVE PROOF OF
SUCH UTOPIAN NIGHTMARES.
SO MANY YOUNG PEOPLE DON'T CARE.
SOCIALISM IS A BRAND THAT
HAPPILY REINVENTS ITSELF WITH
EVERY NAIVE GENERATION.
AOC'S FANS LIKE TO SAY SHE IS
LIVING IN OUR HEADS.
IN FACT IT'S THE POLICIES THAT
LIVE IN OUR HEADS.
THEY SHOULD LIVE THERE.
WE KNOW SO MANY PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN BRUTALIZED BY SUCH IDEA.
WHEN YOU HEAR SOMEONE TALK ABOUT
SOCIALISM LIKE IT'S A FUN NEW
WAY TO PAY DOWN MY COLLEGE DEBT,
YOU'VE GOT TO SCREEN.
PREPARE TO BE CALLED AWFUL
THINGS FOR DOING SO.
TODAY POINTING OUT THE EVIL OF
THE PAST MAKES YOU THE VEIN OF
THE PRESENT.
JESSE, DO KNOW THAT I LOVE?
THE LEFT SUDDENLY WANTS TO
RETURN TO THE 1950s.
>> Jesse: THAT'S A GREAT
POINT.
ALL OF HER IDEAS ARE OUT OF THE
SOCIALIST PLAYBOOK.
I THINK SHE'S TALENTED ON
SOCIAL MEDIA AND SHE'S GOT A BIG
FOLLOWING BUT NOW SHE'S A MEMBER
OF CONGRESS AS A DEMOCRAT AND
THERE ARE CERTAIN RULES OF
DEMOCRAT THAT YOU HAVE TO PLAY
BY.
SHE'S JUST A FRESHMAN.
HE HAS CHANGED -- HE HAS TO
REALIZE PINOCCHIOS OVER
DONALD TRUMP.
SHE'S GETTING FACT-CHECKED ALL
THE TIME BY
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
I AM THE ONLY REASON --
>> Greg: HE IS COMPLEMENTING
HER.
>> Jesse: WHEN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" FACT
CHECKS HER MORE THAN
DONALD TRUMP.
REPUBLICANS CAN USE HER AS A
WAGE ISSUE AGAINST THEIR OWN
PARTY AND THE LEADERSHIP HATES
THAT.
SHE IS HOTDOGGING NANCY PELOSI.
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN LEADERSHIP
ARE THINGS SLOW DOWN A LITTLE
BIT.
LET'S BE HONEST.
THIS REMINDS ME OF A ROOKIE.
GREAT COLLEGE CAREER, NOW THEY
GOT DRAFTED, THEY ENTERED THE
LEAGUE AND GIVING THE OPPOSING
TEAMS A LOT OF BULLETIN BOARD
MATERIAL.
A LOT OF THE VETS ON THE TEAM
DON'T REALLY LIKE HER ALL THAT
MUCH, GETTING CALLED FOR A LOT
OF PERSONAL FLOW
CRACKS -- PERSONAL FOULS
SHE'S IN PAGE SIX A LOT.
SHE MIGHT BURN OUT BUT SHE MIGHT
HAVE A LONG CAREER.
WE DON'T REALLY KNOW YET.
>> Juan: SHE VOTED FOR
NANCY PELOSI AND THEN THE
REPUBLICANS HISSED AT HER
BECAUSE SHE IS GOLD FOR
REPUBLICANS.
THEY ARE MAKING HER THE STAR.
IT'S NOT DEMOCRATS.
IT'S REPUBLICANS WILL LOVE HER.
>> Jesse: REPUBLICANS DIDN'T
PUT HER ON "60 MINUTES."
>> Juan: I THINK THEY DID.
THEY GAVE HER SO MUCH ATTENTION.
>> Jesse: SHE IS WRONG A LOT
OF THE TIME.
>> Juan: WHAT IS SHE WRONG
ABOUT?
>> Jesse: EVERYTHING SHE IS
ADVOCATING ABOUT.
UNIVERSAL HEALTH CARE.
>> Juan: SOCIAL SECURITY?
DO YOU REMEMBER WHEN THAT WAS
RADICAL?
GREAT SOCIETY.
TERRIBLE.
WHAT ABOUT RAISING TAX RATES?
UNDER PRESIDENT ROOSEVELT --
>> Jesse: IF YOU WANT TO THROW
IN WITH THE 70% TAX RATE, YOU
CAN CHECK THAT BOX ON THE RETURN
AND VOLUNTARILY PAY IT.
>> Juan: IF YOU MAKE MORE THAN
10 MILLION.
YOU HAVE NO OBJECTION THAT UNDER
TRUMP RIGHT NOW THE DEFICIT IS
BLOWING SKY-HIGH.
>> Jesse: HE WILL NEVER GET
10 MILLION IF YOU HAVE POLICIES
LIKE THAT.
>> Greg: THE RICH PAID OUT
MORE THAN EVER.
TOP 1% PAYS 40%.
IN 1980, IT WAS 19%.
IT'S NOT AFFECTING THE DEBT.
>> Juan: WHY ARE YOU SAYING
THAT?
>> Greg: WE ARE TOTALLY
INDENT.
>> Juan: THE DEBT HAS BEEN
INCREASING RADICALLY.
>> Greg: THAT'S MY POINT.
IT DOESN'T MATTER HOW MUCH YOU
TAX PEOPLE.
I HAVE ARGUED STOP TAXING
PEOPLE, IT DOESN'T MATTER.
WE ARE SPENDING ATTICS.
IF YOU STOP TAXING OUR COUNTRY
FOR ONE YEAR, $4 TRILLION?
WOULD WE EVEN CARE?
WE WOULD SAVE ALL OF OUR MONEY
AND WE WILL BE IN DEBT BUT WE
DON'T CARE.
>> Juan: WE LIVE IN ANARCHY,
YOU WOULD LOVE THAT.
>> Greg: DANA, ONE THING I'VE
NOTICED, AOC COMES IN AND
BECAUSE OF THE ESTABLISHMENT
DEMOCRATS.
YOU HAVE WHOOPI GOLDBERG ON "THE
VIEW," SAYING HOLD YOUR HORSES,
LADY.
THERE WERE A BUNCH OF DEMOCRATS
BEFORE YOU.
THEY WORKED THERE --  THEIR
BUTTS OFF >> Dana: DEMOCRATS
IN DEEP BLUE DISTRICTS WERE SAYI
IN DEEP BLUE DISTRICTS WERE SAYG
IN DEEP BLUE DISTRICTS WERE SAYT
IN DEEP BLUE DISTRICTS WERE SAYA
IN DEEP BLUE DISTRICTS WERE SAY.
HILLARY CLINTON DIDN'T WIN
BECAUSE NOT ENOUGH DEMOCRATS
WANTED HER TO COME OUT AND WIN.
I KNEW THAT NANCY PELOSI AT SOME
POINT WOULD BE ECLIPSED BY THIS
YOUNGER GENERATION.
I JUST DIDN'T KNOW IT WILL
HAPPEN IN THREE DAYS.
THAT'S PRETTY INTERESTING.
AOC BEAT ONE OF PELOSI'S MOST
ARDENT ALLIES IN CONGRESS.
SHE OWES PELOSI NOTHING.
I DO THINK JESSE MAKES A GREAT
POINT.
>> Jesse: LET THAT SINK IN.
>> Greg: EVERYBODY WENT QUIET.
>> Dana: EVEN I DID.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: IT CAME OUT OF YOUR
MOUTH.
>> Dana: THE MORE SHE TALKS
ABOUT HER IDEAS, THAT YOU COULD
RETROFIT ALL OF AMERICA WITHIN
TEN YEARS WITH RENEWABLE ENERGY.
POLICY WISE, YOU HAVE TO GO
THAT'S NOT POSSIBLE.
WHY NOT JUST SAY IT?
>> Greg: EVERY DAY SHE HAS A
"BUILD THE WALL" COMMENT.
I THINK THE UPSIDE IS WHEN SHE'S
TALKING ABOUT SOCIALISM IN
SWEDEN NOR SHE'S TALKING ABOUT
70% RATE, IT REMINDS OTHER
PEOPLE TO READ UP ON IT AND READ
FIND OUT THE TRUTH.
>> Emily: IN SWEDEN, IT'S A
VIOLENT REALITY.
SWEDEN IS GOING DOWN IN FLAMES.
THEY ARE A PARALLEL SOCIETY.
VIOLENT CRIMES HAVE RISEN BY
40%.
>> Juan: IF I BOG GREG, IT'S A
100% JUMP IN CRIME.
>> Emily: THE USE OF A
FORMERLY HOMOGENOUS SOCIETY IN A
TINY COUNTRY IS NOT ACCURATE.
IT'S NOT APPLICABLE.
FOR HE AOC, HER TIME TO BE
POPULAR IS OVER.
NOW IT'S HER TIME TO GET TO
WORK.
LIKE EVERYONE, WE COULD BENEFIT
FROM SPECIFICITY AND ACCURACY IN
CONGRESS.
IT WOULD HELP FURTHER HURT
BECAUSE OF THE PEOPLE THAT
COULD --
EVEN IF SHE ISN'T OWED ANYTHING
BY ANYONE OR SHE DOESN'T OWE,